friendship
[Music]
[Music]
give it up for the two friends
feel free to pick up the mics put it
right by your mouth um
a little
yes
[Music]
what uh what part of americana did you
grow up in did you grow up in
from
[Music]
what game do you think
[Music]
bad vegan
have you ever dated a trump supporter
unfortunately
that you are like taylor swift on the
floor she was like
like she had money but she was like you
know
family as well to do
seems like a lot of guys like white
cheddar
yes
uh
i feel like you should not have a shirt
on right now like that is the guy that
you're feeling
these shorts yeah
tattoos
kids man we got kids date night with
the one be on the street bro
i guess that's a good topic to cover
wait are you married are you married
we're we're kurt russell and goldie hawn
man
is this an open relationship what's
going on and she's really fertile so
that's why you're worried about your
dicks right yeah
it's not really yours
the kids from the movie overboard uh
they were very unruly but not my kids
are like saints and you wouldn't say
they're my children you're like that's
your kids i think your kids take care of
you take care of you yes my kids look at
me like i'm a [ __ ] idiot or maybe
your kids actually have a different dad
maybe you've been dead this whole time
and it's six cents
racist joke about asians being good at
video games
uh ashlyn are you uh what's the last
date a relationship
what a loser
[Applause]
but i hope you're different i hope
you're doing this what happens when you
put your name in the book you need to
break the pattern i'm trying here
she's broken up hopefully your ex is
watching and getting super jealous
[Music]
tell me about your ex
um
but then as the relationship went on it
became
really apparent that we were just too
different
he's taylor swift
i think she was wrong
the worst mistake she's ever made
dear john i know the story
yeah maybe not
i'm that shitty dj that stole the
lightning
the
summertime she wrote that [ __ ] i love
your references
you're from chicago chicago
um so yeah you're from chicago uh you
know you gotta talk fast before you get
shot let me explain let me explain i got
kids i got kids uh so when's the last
time uh you've been seriously seeing
someone that's not your current not your
current girl
[ __ ] man it's good forever
[Music]
with her since like your twenties your
twenties
and now you're in europe now you're in
your
thirties
does it look like four years
i'm born in the 80s dude so i know
russell [ __ ]
is
[Music]
slap a green sweater on him
are you doing this on purpose
this is like back to the future ferris
bueller's tail updated references
he watches movies uh ashley what uh what
kind of movies
would you uh would you take on a date on
a date batman sounds good that was
pretty good
that's a good movie to talk about
there's a lot going on
a lot of
like it's a childhood
[Music]
he's doing
[Applause]
yeah he knows he knows he knows the
current pop culture if you want to uh
rachel or courtney
going up on a date ashlyn and colton
going on a date together together what a
nice shirt
fancy mustache
i'm excited
yeah and then he came out that he had a
girl i was like that's not that's not
cool to do to you you know
okay let's cover the topic you also have
a girl i do not have a girl not for sure
i do not have a girl
yeah
no no kids either no for sure hell yeah
like how do you feel about when you go
on a date to that or you just like
remember
yeah
yeah no
no
not with me on your back like whispering
sweet nothing's on the way down
no definitely not the person abstract
i want to be strapped to the instructor
yeah no no that's i that's what i do for
it that's what i do for a living okay
you know what i think it's better now
okay that makes me feel a lot safer yeah
okay yeah for sure
and time and time give it up for
ashland and colton dowling
wow you like to skydive straight into
it's just a part of this
okay so can i call you
yes it's uh that's how we get started
i'll call you hands kids kid
okay sorry dude i'm not a comedian you
know
he's not a comedian
[Music]
you got that uh powerful
that girl that uh tricked everyone into
giving them her blood her blood
or maybe even three well maybe three is
that like your home business
yeah
yeah i mean you go all the way
yeah if you're willing to go skydiving
with me i know
that you know you have trust in that you
know i get tests and [ __ ] you know okay
but why sit for what
you know you do std tests before you
jump out the plane yeah well if you're
willing to put your life on the line and
you're willing to put your health and
[ __ ] on the line
and have risky sex without a condom yeah
so you would get tested
no i get tested
but she would get tested
with her life you know what i'm saying
for sure i get it i get it wait ashlyn i
think this guy is your type am i right
i'm open to it i like how he looks oh
yeah hell yeah thank you i like the way
you look too
i like the way you look fun to talk so
far i'm enjoying this yeah hell yeah
where are you from
from nevada oh you're two years ago okay
reno yeah
okay are you from reno
no i just know a billionaire from there
are we name dropping
no okay specifically not i just remember
this is being recorded my sister would
hate me if i told you the next thing
about that
it's his brother-in-law
he knows a billionaire there's not that
many of them just google billionaires in
nevada and you can find out exactly who
he's talking about i feel like there's a
lot of billionaires there
i guess so maybe dana white
um
speaking of dana white
uh what are you guys uh
going to do on a date together ashlynn
and colton where would you guys see
yourself like riding mechanical balls
yeah you're a pretty adventurous guy i
feel like yeah that vibe yeah my first
thought was like mini golf but i feel
like that's not it's not extreme enough
that is a mustache
you
know i want to take you out like if
you're not going to go skydiving maybe
you start like zip lining i'm in for
that like bouldering you know i like zip
lining i do some wrong take her to costa
rica to zipline i think that would be a
good idea if we were on the bachelorette
right now i would take you to costa rica
and go ziplining with you right think of
this as like the low budget bachelorette
like we could work with that yeah
i just feel like if you're not willing
to go skydiving with me you traveling to
a different country to me with on a
first date feels like a little crazy i'm
getting some red flags over here
but like the adrenaline the adrenaline
would be crazy high for both of you like
you'd be scared that she was willing to
do it yeah
because that's like crazy girl [ __ ] on
the first date i feel like do you do
drugs no yeah good that's a good thing
because
i'd be
i'd be scared that she was gonna sell my
body to like put cocaine in there and
then they would mule me back is this the
impression i give off
costa rica just yells cocaine to me but
maybe that's just everywhere
i feel like you're like a stoner horse
girl it's not i wouldn't think any other
drugs of you besides weed maybe
nope no
no for me either you used to
no just completely christian dare
program worked on not christian
uh full-time i do marketing time i teach
yoga
what kind of yoga
like regular cold or hot is it too flow
i hate the flow i'm like let me sit at
one pose real quick
that's a different type of yoga that's
not vinyasa that's what i'm talking
about yeah i do the flow vinyasa classes
what's your best pose
if i was walking down the street how
would you catch my eye with a pose which
pose
which pose would you show me or she'll
catch my uh
no i wouldn't i'd be worried about her
dirty ass hands i'm not
i'm walking down the street she has her
hands on the ground i'm not going to
stop
that's how i can tell you're not gravely
hand job yeah block hand
uh i guess i would say like dancer where
you're standing on one foot and then you
have your foot lifted behind you and
you're holding it yeah that's going to
stop me for sure all right cool i would
love to see that
you're going to make me do this in a
dress funny dancer i was there to build
jewel but i don't think i did it right
wow dude i don't know i don't know
yeah no ice coffee yeah
um but uh yeah is there any pose that
you could do maybe you could do the tree
pose a tree pose i guess i could do
okay a professional yogi
being a tree
watch colton's boner increase
she did it
and you're wearing green you really look
like a tree
i like that
game one with the tree so we're gonna
yeah that did for me that did it for me
i would have stopped for sure
like what i would have said hey
what's your name again
ashlynn
no no that's what i would have said too
on this stream
and then i would have
i think we met before that's my pickup
line i go did we meet before
and it works
sometimes it's just pretending to be a
tree and you go to park spot yeah that's
like all right
that's a good point if you're doing that
on this quarter and you're calling me
the weird one for maybe knowing you
you're the one that made her do that in
public
um yeah i mean i think it's awesome that
you are more concerned about the hands
on the cement than the foot on the thigh
like aren't you worried like
that that there's gonna be a little
detritus on the you know like if she
puts her foot on her thigh like that
like i don't i don't go
um
i don't do are you a uh inner thigh
licker
yes oh
definitely if i have the option or like
if you have a pube on your tongue that's
how you get it off right
he taught me that trick oh
better
i just added like a little sixth street
i just act like i'm a little bit more
dirty than i am i just give it a little
spit a spit at it
that's your pickup line
sure
yeah
hold on can you do any yoga poses uh
it's mostly
no i guess i could do tree pose but
that's already been done you know can
you do that no one would and she
wouldn't want my foot on my thigh
yeah that's a big turn-off
guy
yeah sky pose an impression of you
skydiving
what's up baby girl
you wanna go get ice cream after this
oh you look so good with that wind in
your head girl
he turns mexican when he sky dives
it's loud you have to talk like that
yo what's up girl
yeah that's a good point you're making
me breathless
here
what wait i feel like your favorite
movie might also be lion king
oh what's your favorite movie
i did just watch lion king um i did
watch the new west side story and
actually i'm gonna say new west side
story
nice not the old one okay you have real
emperor's new grooves groove buttons
it's just a shirt not boy it's just a
shirt
i get why you say that though
no uh
you uh what's what's like the
craziest thing you've done in that shirt
probably this yeah i kissed a dude today
whoa
that's
crazy at the gym he was my gay friend
and uh you know he just wanted to kiss
on the pecker and i just get a little
on the packer that's a good point i said
pecker i did mean i gave him
a peck
on his lips
and i was i it was i was like oh dude
you got sweaty lips bro
i guess that's what they mean by
peckerwood yeah that's exactly what they
mean
have you ever kissed a
member of the same sex as you ashlynn i
have yes hello
little peck doesn't mean anything you
know it's just we all pack witch lips
upper visual did you like it
yeah she was pretty cool we dated for a
bit
whoa
she is now in austin i shouldn't be
surprised
this is pretty austin
yeah she's from nevada
yeah bisexuality
crazy would you imagine where's the san
francisco
yeah that is kind of crazy that's smart
your soul is shaming us
molly
actually is important though what's the
craziest thing you've ever done like
what's seen
have you ever kissed someone on the
pecker
um
yeah because i hate sucking dicks so
sometimes when they ask i'm just like
and that's it so there's a loophole
about it yeah yeah
i only do it if i'm getting paid i'm
jewish it's like in the torah we don't
like to do that
that's hot is it the just
mouthful feeling or
you're just you like to talk or
i like to talk
i have a little bit of a
reflex okay so you're embarrassed that
you might throw up on his dick have you
done that before
you've thrown up on a dude's dick so
many times when i was 18 i was in a
hotel room with my boyfriend and
we started [ __ ] in the bathtub and
like what why just for fun like freaking
about this
sexuality
that's not comfortable it's hard
surfaces
i know it was fun i mean there was water
in the bathtub like we were talking
about okay but we were kind of
waterproof it was full of i thought it
was dry like you guys are just trying to
clean up easier
it's a good idea that's why i let my dog
[ __ ] in the bathtub
we're going to have sex go in the
bathtub
if she really has to go if it's an
emergency she does that it's really
smart actually it's really gross
actually
[ __ ] dude
there's a [ __ ] in your [ __ ] bathtub
and you're like oh normal
do it regularly it's not a pee pee pad
but if she has a little stomach problem
she knows that's where to go it's an
easier cleanup house you were in the
back growl and like how did you train
her
when she's sick when you're feeling
upset well like it has to go she doesn't
go inside unless she doesn't feel good
so that's that's it how did you train
her did she often not feel good that's
what i'm asking
like one time she did [ __ ] because i
knew she had a stomachache and i was
like
and i like showed her the shower and
then now i leave the shower curtain open
and she knows if if she has to that's
where she knows yeah
don't tell me twice yeah yeah yeah no
she's a she's a genius okay um but
anyways i was [ __ ] in the bathtub
it's for dog [ __ ] and [ __ ] in the
[ __ ]
hotel bathtub which is arguably grosser
than a dog [ __ ] in a bathtub
and uh
he was like let's get out and like [ __ ]
not in a bathtub so i was like okay
obviously it gets a little i gotta plump
it up it you know fluff it up because it
got a little soft in transition that's
my job
straight am i right
yard how
and yard house will [ __ ] you up right so
i'm just going and then i'm like oh no
and i just turn around and i like open
the curtain of the shower and i puke and
i like clothes like oh my god that's so
embarrassing because i was 18 i had
shame i don't know like dog like dog
owner when you're sick
[ __ ] in the shower
don't look in there and he was like i
won't i won't and then like while
we were like doing something he just
went like this and like opened up the
curtain and saw it floating in the water
and just pointed and laughed at me for
like two minutes and it was so
mortifying
of course
why would you be like
there was a curtain there was a curtain
he kept [ __ ] me he wasn't that
grossed out he just thought it was funny
what position were you in
i was honestly like
yeah were you [ __ ] and he looked in
the bathtub
that was maybe giving him a bumpkin
what's a blumpkin
is that when you're getting a [ __ ] on
the toilet
oh they're [ __ ] yeah
and you're worried about throw up you
should have just pointed to a [ __ ] and
then like you think might have stick off
is gross i see your [ __ ] in the toilet
we're learning so much today ashlynn
have you ever given someone a blumkin
absolutely not and never will have you
ever puked on a peen no
really pretty proud of that these girls
never have a gag reflex
have you ever actually ridden a horse or
do you just look like it ridden
so uh
how long did you ride horses for
i mean it's not like a regular thing
like you just have done it yeah you do
like horseback riding dates you've been
on a horseback riding no but that would
be so fun
i jump on a horse sorry good question i
need two more words can you j can you i
make the horse jump over [ __ ] no i've
always wanted to do that while shooting
a bow and arrow at a watermelon
i've always wanted to do that while
giving a
blunken maybe that's why you have a gag
reflex you just go too hard
yeah i i do go kind of hard that's kind
of my thing um
great ollie's getting uncomfortable
you want to replace colton
well we could switch
but i'm kind of worried because i've
gained weight like i'm scared and
they're gonna have to put big balloons
on me like in nathan for you
speaking of references what is happening
we're trying to steal both dates
the bisexual thing has kind of gotten in
my head okay and now i'm thinking about
eating a horse girl's [ __ ] so
i am very flattered but i would like to
put out there that i am straight i did
try to date a girl it didn't work out
yeah yeah but not a girl with
well i'm available
no i haven't done that before you got me
there yeah yeah yeah
i can show you
the world
i thought her favorite movie was lion
king not aladdin
it's close enough i know she likes
aladdin too
right aladdin's a good movie yeah yeah
yeah you do it's a little ethnic for my
taste yeah a little infant for my taste
as well
i prefer west side story
yeah a totally straight guy that loves
west side swimming it's a good movie
covers a lot of topics
what's your favorite part of it
uh
[Music]
when he just goes around the city
yelling maria in this song it's called
maria and a bunch of people just look at
him like i'm not maria but he keeps on
doing it that's just a funny thing
because what if i did that that's just a
funny thing to do he's like a youtube
prankster i thought you were straight
but now i'm questioning things wait why
why are you questioning things because i
like art
yeah that is kind of oh hey guys
you can't like
that's why we all dress great and we
have bad taste in views
still thinking about how bisexual is
crazy so like okay behind on the time
okay where are you all from you're from
new york i thought yeah okay and you
just think bisexuality is insane
i mean i didn't expect her to just offer
that up um i think it's very awesome i
don't judge you i think that you should
go to heaven but
okay
and you're from where
loxahatchee florida okay redneck [ __ ]
yeah
no and that's why i understand that
she's a horse girl i feel like i'm gonna
ask you all after this and you're just
gonna be like
well give it up for a cold
we got actually two more women
call me mr stelio girl
um
yeah so i know you're not bisexual
anymore but maybe you could get into it
for the next date sure sounds fun
okay we're gonna get a woman forced her
to be gay again
marceline
marceline coming up
that is my friend's cat's name
so i think she might be gay let's see
who it is
oh
wow what a huge gay that we got coming
up marceline give it up for marceline
and uh
the other person was
ashlynn
i'm sorry
ashlynn and marceline
um you're really running through them
today
it's okay i'm ready
all right yeah thank you yeah um so i've
heard a lot about you
i hope good things yeah all good things
from the back of the room yeah yeah i
like your tattoos what does this one's
thank you
uh to die would be an awfully big
adventure
nice
and then you have like this flower one
yes
thank you
so uh do you have horses is that what's
going on no you just like them yeah
they're kind of cool
i don't think that's like my personality
what's your personality tell me um
i'd say pretty fun i think i guess being
like healthy is my thing which kind of
annoys people
what do you do for fun
watch documentaries read
yoga
do you watch like murder documentaries i
do
oh
do you
not at all no that's fine
really finding common ground is the key
step in a day give it up for marceline
and
ashlynn i like how you say that being
fun is your personality and then when
she asks you what you do for fun you
said watch documentaries read books
what's the most fun documentary you've
seen recently
the most fun documentary i feel like
it's the fungi one i haven't seen that
one
the mushrooms chip but i haven't seen
that yet that one's pretty cool you do
mushrooms
nope i did it once did not have a good
time okay okay anyways sorry yeah she's
sober
she only does
copious amounts of alcohol earth
i think that's fine
what did you do while you were on
mushrooms did you [ __ ]
no i was in amsterdam when i was on
mushroom so we just kind of hung out on
a hill with all the other stoned people
did you get a prostitute
no we didn't
just to hang out with i i know you
didn't [ __ ] but like
to hang out with one would be kind of
cool like in the window
oh i know you're talking about yeah we
did walk around the red light district
we did go we saw um like a live sex show
that was pretty cool were people just
[ __ ] live yeah i've always wanted to
do that they're pretty cool
yeah no i really want [ __ ] and to go
to one yeah you want to watch yeah yeah
i love being participating yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] okay is it do you pay for that do
you you pay to go in like oh yeah yeah
she said she supports sex work that's
what she oh i believe in supporting
local just hand the money to your
friends
you know
yeah yeah i got an only fans yeah that's
subscribe you know i can give money down
if i see a homeless like few people on
the block i'm just like okay well you're
going to have to put on a little
song and dance for me if you want a doll
make some work for it for the dollars is
that why everyone's been masturbating on
the streets
are you the cause of this
um probably
but it's cool uh i think it's made
homeless women hate me so that's the
thing i'm dealing with now
yeah they're like one took my cigarette
up her [ __ ] in front of me
in front of vulcan gas company
did she smoke it
um i think
no she didn't get to light it she just
got mad at me she turned on me she
called me fat and ugly she shoved my
cigarette up her [ __ ]
in front of everyone and then tried to
fight me
wow i would do that after i fought you
it's kind of puts you at a combative
disadvantage of a cigarette inside your
body as you like she was used to it
yeah
it seemed really comfortable for her
she was you know that uh puts on extra
pounds you know it makes her heavier so
she can easily beat people maybe i
should pull a few out of mine
yeah if you uh ever feel like too
stressed out feel free to
take the cigarettes out your [ __ ] and
puff away
um mars
how you've been oh we got sam up here
thanks sam that's for me
that was completely random and weird
actually
okay you have water
yeah sam has standards
i walked in and he was like you look
amazing as always so i don't think he's
he's in a mood
he's feeling randy tonight
uh mars uh what's your dating history
like in terms of women
um
i've had a lot of uh sexual tension with
women before and i i dated one uh last
summer
she was my summer fling
uh 32 year old mother
uh she sounds like a predator
me or her
oh uh i'm 25.
the last summer you were 24 that's a
little that's cut that's cutting it
closed in my opinion
she's not no
no she was a predator yeah yeah yeah her
her and her boyfriend were both
predators but i like i knew it
okay you know
i knew it's so funny
yeah yeah
like to catch a predator [ __ ] i feel
like
you're like debate willingly
and you just let it keep going in that
situation yes because i had a lot to
gain
like they're rich
um
they lived in a really good spot in town
yeah
what's a really good spot
it was right next to barton springs and
i was there like every day and i was
like i'm not gonna drive home
what the [ __ ]
nice yeah
you just like floated around
in the really cold water yeah and then i
floated on over to their house and
you know did you ever throw up in their
bathtub
left a floater did you ever give either
of them a blumpkin
um no but it was disgust
wow i feel like it's better to give a
dude a blumpkin because like for a woman
you have to get closer to the
to the action some people have audi's
audi buttholes well all men have autism
talking about that are kind of look like
almost weird dicks so that could work
nice you don't have to get that not me i
haven't any designer yeah i'm just
saying i'm not shaming you
um i'm shaming any of you audi [ __ ] i
was just saying yeah we we love the
audis here
at other people
not belly buttons so that's kind of
gross yeah that's gross have you ever uh
sucked on a belly button before either
of you no okay that sounds no i don't
really like the smell of belly buttons
just gonna say have you ever smelled
your own yeah it's belly buttons you're
[ __ ] weird
it's so bad sometimes me my friend n
never mind
and youtube never mind
if we dated would you deep clean my
belly button for me
depends how long have we been together
say like
two months in a day
okay that sounds kind of fun is she like
looking cleaner too yeah yeah yeah like
specify uh i don't know um what's your
preference i feel like a q-tip would be
smart
yeah but like you need to get some spit
or something in there you know it's like
uh it's like against the walls like in
the crevices of the belly button i see
where you're getting that yeah it's
important why
why won't you just take care of me
why won't you love
me i just realized that someone assumed
only i wanted fries
yeah where's my fries what
the [ __ ] is happening what kind of way
luckily i have all this kettle corn from
kelly's
i can dip that in ketchup
and being fat
so what's the craziest thing a guy has
ever done on a date
i don't know i can't think of anything
off the top of my head
what about for you
tried to go on a second date
damn
man always
hopefully have either of you ever in any
relationship like uh started a fight in
public like in a parking lot or like at
a restaurant or a party
no but they always try to start a fight
with me and i just like i just smile
really politely
and then everyone in the room is
uncomfortable crazy girl
that's infuriating
that's a good tactic i'm keeping that
for next time yeah and then i just i
just like eat my food and leave like i'm
not i don't give a [ __ ] i feel like
ashlynn would dig her keys into the car
of his whatever whatever four-wheel
drive
have you ever uh
got done that
have i done that yeah like uh
taken out anger physically
uh no that's that's completely awesome
that you haven't done that
uh
i've thought about keying girls cars
more than i have guys cars yeah because
they're bad at driving no i'm kidding
i'm asian i can say that
he can say that for sure but i don't
know if i'm whose car would you play
that what whose car would you key um
probably my neighbors
neighbors that she's kind of a dumb [ __ ]
you can say that um
yeah i mean
how else are they gonna learn
thought about it you could carve [ __ ]
into a car oh wait no no she literally
can't drive she doesn't have a car but
if there was someone
if it was someone whose car i would key
it would be hers you would buy her a car
just to key it
yeah or just key her house
i'll just get her a [ __ ] kia that
[ __ ] sucks
we could do this all day
um give it up for uh marceline
she went on a date with a woman we'll
try to get you up here with a man
we got one man left if you want if
you're a man and you want to go on a
date
oh that's hers
god damn all i have is kettle corn
we got gabe bickford
gabrielle
where is he at
is he at the patio
sanjak no sanjak isn't doing a mic
tonight
here he comes gabe bickberg
welcome to the big stage from the patio
to here he's the one he might be the one
let's keep saying that no i think he did
gabe bickford and ashlynn they're going
on a date welcome to the ashland show
what's up what's up
what's up i wasn't smoking a cigarette
do you do you mind that
no no you can [ __ ] up your body how you
want to oh thank god because i'm doing
it i'm thinking all right all right
i gotta ask you something um how how old
do you think i am
oh that's a good question
like mid to late 20s
yes no close hot cold
how do you do you mind if i ask how old
am i yeah 24. 24.
i'm 21 years old
really yeah all right i gotta stop
smoking look at me bro
look like [ __ ]
look like i'm [ __ ] what'd you say 20
20 mid-20s mid-20s yeah that's not good
it's not good
too late mid to late
i think it's just a deep voice
facial hair yeah i got the facial hair
if i shave i look like a baby if i
should ever look like i'm 17.
it's not good you like 17 year old no
i'm gonna keep it like this
yeah that'd be perfect where are you
from you said you're from nevada yeah
thanks for remembering i've never met
anyone from nevada no you have
damn that's crazy i know i've been here
my whole life you like the city i do
yeah how long you're in town for
well i live here permanently you live
here permanently oh yeah
give it up for ashlynn and gabe
he knows a little bit about her but not
where she lives which is which might be
a good thing yeah yeah
gaba
what uh what made you ask her how old
she thinks
you are this is just a conversation i've
been having with people perpetually for
the past like six months every every
time i meet someone new they're like
what are you like 27 and i just got to
say they're like nope how long have you
looked like this
i've i've been able to grow a beard like
this since i was like 18. yeah
yeah and the voice does not have choice
yeah i guess yeah when did your voice
turn like that uh 14.
hey mom can i go to prom yeah
can you help me pick out my suit mom i
don't know what i'll get keep trying my
time for me
i don't know have you ever narrated
anything
i used to do the announcements at my
high school
they're like why is the 40 year old man
telling me about yeah they thought that
people i i announced like this like
state band thing in my high school too
and a lot of the directors were they
were like is that a man they're like no
it's just this kid we're paying him like
50 bucks
they underpaid me so much i was there
for like legit 14 hours and they get he
only gave me like a 20. he told me he
was going to give me like 50. he gave me
like 20.
i'm up on the phone pretending to be
some gangster yeah [ __ ] where's
my money face irs [ __ ] where you at
i think you should stop smoking
cigarettes you should get healthy with
her work out with her go find that guy
and beat the [ __ ] out of him oh yeah
[ __ ] you miss a parent you [ __ ] [ __ ]
no i was the teacher that shorted you
yeah the band director at my high school
yeah damn you should accuse him of
touching kids like he always did
where did you go to school i went to uh
liberty hill high school school of hard
docs yeah
uh ashlynn uh what do you think about uh
have you ever dated someone with like a
weird voice
[Music]
uh no i mean but like if we're
categorizing him like he doesn't have a
weird voice it's just deep yeah thank
you yeah welcome do you think it's hot
really weird yeah
okay
all right what's up
he has an oral fixation he's smarter
um now he's a girl
yeah yeah
uh ashlyn so have you ever dated someone
younger than you
no i usually go for older
well
wait you've been having a pattern of
choosing bad guys maybe you need to go
the opposite way and go younger and give
maybe you should be the predator
yeah i'm so i'm so young yeah i have
[ __ ] i have no life experience you
can teach me so much you're really good
teach them about horses yeah
and yoga
i can't do that [ __ ]
you look you look great yeah he's stiff
as a boy yeah bend him over if you cried
look man you could teach him how to
breathe
yeah yeah i need help with that
hits of cigarettes
he has to relearn again after all the
cigs i'm around him a lot he smokes a
lot too much
too much how did this guy say jesus
oh you just sound like that
no uh ashlynn uh
that's have you ever smoked cigarettes
nope
hmm that's weird you're from nevada
you're allowed to or vaped nope okay
that's good that's good you're a gold
star that would be embarrassing if you
vaped
yeah
so you think like people who vape are
like into tick-tock and sort of like uh
you know
whatever
or like
people that vapor into tick-tock and
whatever like ask your question
yeah you think people who vape are like
say lit a lot and say fam and
see that i can see that happening yeah
so let's pretend like uh gabe is like
gen z and like he's very very young and
you're like trying to speak on his level
like could you could you like give us an
example of something you'd say like
about a party
you want me to talk to a person three
years younger than me as if they're in a
different generation
yeah
use the lingo of the of the time
yeah
i mean you've been using straight
english like the queen's english
try it try to be like uh you know an
acid rapper or like a
person who smokes a lot of weed
can't do any of those because i've never
done that
you did it wow you sound like a stoner
already
um
wait i'm actually a question that's off
topic is that okay
yeah i've been doing that all you're a
great host molly what the [ __ ]
a little nervous i usually have a really
good read on people but you're kind of
hard like i know people are gonna think
horse but like
what is your pet you have a pet i do
have a pet is it a cat or a dog it's a
dog i'm a dog person really yeah because
you like at first seem like a cat person
like 100 she has a cat the more you
speak
i saw a dog yeah what are like the
things that say i'm a dog person um it's
really just like a vibe okay it's really
just like an aura kind of thing are you
a dog person cat person i'm a cat person
yeah okay yeah yeah that's gay don't
tell people that
these kids you don't have to do anything
really you know they just hang out way
less maintenance yeah but there's no
man's best friend
that's not
if you're a man you need a best friend
that's a dog not a cat
or you know her favorite movie is lion
king and you're just trying to impress
her right now
i don't know trying to seem gentle
yeah yeah i'm a gentle man with a voice
like okay you are a real gentleman a
gentle baby yeah yes 21.
i do like cats though i think cats are
cool why are you thinking so deeply
about it because i'm trying i'm i don't
know i i just
i'm sorry that i like cats
it's okay you don't have to apologize
for like i [ __ ] up no you didn't can
we get a redo please
no i'm [ __ ] around what kind of dog
you have
it's a good question i adopted him so
he's kind of a mutt but the shelter told
me a black mouth curve mix
oh what yeah black mouth mix that sounds
like a slur
yeah that dog right there you're a black
man like what's the [ __ ]
i feel like he speaks the lingo of our
time the black job that poor dog
he's just sitting there waiting to get
adopted and everyone's like no he's a
black male don't get him like what
because once had a black mouth and this
is true
you ate blueberries
i i flew to miami for work i had a scene
and i had projectile diarrhea on the
flight
and
is this part of the scene and no and
then and when i got to my hotel the
night before my scene i was like oh
thank god they have pepto bismo in the
lobby so i like took a tab of it like
before
i went to bed and when i woke up to
brush my teeth right before i am going
to my scene i like opened my mouth and
my entire mouth and tongue is just pitch
black
and i didn't put two and two together
but i googled it pepto bismol can do
that to your mouth
so yes i have had it exactly we're
learning so much yesterday wow yeah
maybe your dog just drinks a lot of
pepto-bismol
sure
yeah i was able to like scrub it off but
it like took like five times to do it
yeah you tried scrubbing your dog's
mouth
no he's kind of like born with it
i can't really do much about that oh he
literally has a black mouth yes his
tongue is black
his blackness she's not trying to make
him
or less of himself hans like he is who
he is and she accepts him as that what a
beautiful dog owner you are when you say
black mouth i thought it was like a
black mouth region of england like
that's the region that they're from
they're from the black mouth mountains
or some [ __ ] like that's what i thought
but he literally oh okay that is the
pirate's name
old black mouth mel john
[ __ ] it my friend has a black mouth and
a black face and uh and a black comic
yeah maybe
anyways
me too both are there any other dudes
that want to come up tonight
any fellas want to take a risk is curtis
in here
curtis curtis curtis curtis
get up courtney get
uh
ashlynn you can go on
a date with curtis now how do you feel i
was kind of digging gabe but i'm open to
curtis well you can see him after the
show okay okay no dude
hi
hi
curtis and ashland
pick up the mic and uh
oh i need to pick it up yeah yeah yeah
okay i got it
all right
hi how are you i'm good so i i need to
tell you oh not to bring me up here i
got engaged three weeks ago so i know
you got mad the last person lived with
somebody so i just get that out here
okay that's fair yeah
so thank you for telling me beforehand i
appreciate that yeah you know good
communication
yeah
yeah yeah so you like yoga i do like
yoga yeah
i hate yoga it's really boring i have
horrible adhd i can't stand so for that
long it's it's can be hard you have to
focus and yeah
what do you like to do for fun um i play
hockey so like the opposite yoga nice
yeah okay yeah how long have you been
doing hockey um
how old am i i'm 29 i was like three
when went on ice skates so wow someone
do the math for me i can't i don't do
that long time yeah yeah nice
congrats on your engagement thank you
how long have you guys been together um
three years so this is actually my first
date in
three years i guess yeah i'm honored
yeah i know
we got about like what take ten seconds
left probably so i should cherish this
yeah yeah absolutely yeah um
i don't know you have a nice smile thank
you you're welcome
i don't know i don't know
you've already entered time
there we go
say it back to her
you're rusty but you're supposed to say
you're welcome have a nice smile this is
recording well i'm instructing you to do
it doesn't seem that genuine so do
like that you didn't pick out i want him
to be my puppet and i want to pull his
strings and make him say and do things
curtis was a hockey player and he moved
to austin texas home of the hockey oh i
don't i don't live here i'm here for
work oh nice yeah what do you do for
work um i sell technology believe it or
not
that sounds so vague everything is
technology i know that's that's the joke
i think you're comedian maybe you
understand that yeah it wasn't a very
good one
uh what kind of technology do you sell
um
data backups and like recoveries it's
really exciting and even more very you
get me some more icloud storage
uh
no so uh
where are you from i'm from st louis i
love chicago oh okay cool that's they
have a lot of hockey there the black
whatever black hole yeah this is from st
louis and like anti-blackhawks
black mountains maybe they're just
drinking pepto-bismol
um so you haven't been on a date in
three years you're engaged you guys have
been on on dates but not with a new
person with a human being yeah
yeah
that's awesome uh how did you propose
um
i will get down on one knee that's
typically i think we're supposed to yeah
no tell the story like where were you
what was the build-up
well it wasn't really build up because
i've been dating her for three years and
we lived together once i showed up to
where she was at the uh conservatory she
knew she was gonna get proposed to so it
wasn't really like us like it was a
surprise when i showed up there but like
she knew what was going on because
they're like she works at a conservatory
no her friend brought her to the
conservatory and then i showed up and
then the second i showed up she like
knew what was up but then i just did it
there did you make sure her nails were
done first yes
okay he's a job guy he's a good guy
everyone give it up for curtis that's a
good guy thing to do
no one wants to give it up to you yeah i
know well it's a pretty boring first
date when we were talking about my
engagement i think well yeah i brought
it up yeah you brought it up last time
he got called out for it for for hiding
it so i didn't want to be that guy
the whole time yeah i could have i guess
work on your lines i don't have children
either so like i could have you know
gotten around that yeah that's good
that's good just engaged if you break
his home it'll only hurt two people yeah
i know so it's not as big of a deal
yeah his seed is obviously not that
strong that's kind of a good thing
i mean i've had issues in the past where
the guy i'm with it's too strong i'm off
the sauce i haven't been calmed in in a
while it's really sad
that's tough that's tough in texas too
isn't it yeah yeah it is tough in texas
rough and tough in texas yeah yeah yeah
well uh ashlyn you've been on like seven
dates uh
i really commend you for your service
you're really helping the incel
community here in austin welcome uh
thank you so much we're gonna have uh
colin what's his name
curtis go on another date
uh but give it up for ashlynn
she made the show what it is today
thank you so much
mvp she's gonna go find gabe
gabe where are you at
he's probably coloring or
doing finger painting
oh we only got one name in here and it's
quinn
quinn go on a date with a man who's
engaged
oh quinn's a little
okay well now you do so best behavior
let's go
hi how are you
good i have more to work with here
because you haven't had six other days
in front of everybody so wow uh well
watching this positive i can ask you a
question i guess
[ __ ] would you like to do
um i like to uh
buck that question not no i'm not that
well um i that's a harder question than
i thought it was going to be you know
hobbies than probably like hanging with
my dog i like to like paint my dog is
your dog a slur too a slurp
wow
she's a french bulldog okay
that's pretty basic dog that's pretty
nicely pretty basic dog yeah only like
two thousand dollars so basically just
spend all your money on it probably i
didn't buy it but well then it's perfect
sugar daddy buy it for you or like no my
father did like same thing yeah
same
same same
how long are you in austin um i leave
wednesday morning i think
very cool yeah i don't i don't know how
many days that is i got here yesterday
weeks are hard numbers are
there's only seven of them in a week you
know well it's subtraction i'm not good
at math i understand
i feel that i feel that
give it up for quinn and curtis
very self-effacing you know very humble
i'm not that smart i'm not good at math
you know all these uh wonderful dates i
always go to engage guys i've never been
on a date and been like what do you like
to do for fun and she's like i like to
[ __ ]
it only happens for you curtis lucky dog
for sure
beyonce is watching this like
i feel like you could have just left
that at i've never been on a date and
we'd all be like it's
true wait should i just get rusted
yeah quinn
should i throw up on han's dick yeah
if i can watch that's hot in the bathtub
right
or on the toilet we'll see what my mood
is dealer's choice i'm a little stinker
you know
the way you said that
it's very hot
so quinn uh what's uh what's the last
date you went on
um i don't know if it was like a date or
not i went out i met a guy for a drink
friday
um uh someone that you met online or jan
hinge on a hinge date pinch day oh
uh did you delete the app afterwards
because that's the whole thing right oh
no
still very
still very much so using it uh it was
like a short-lived date
why what happened that made it so
short-lived
um
i don't know it's kind of like a
sometimes like the the vibes are off the
energy
yeah that wasn't his words predator he
said that he said
say that well we start talking about
energies and stuff like that oh he
sounds was he on mushrooms no
he doesn't it's not a date with culture
but he
but it was
he didn't say with me but we just like
brought up energies a lot and then i
didn't hear from rapture
so he said your vibes were off maybe
he's also older than me so how much
older nine years that's weird that's
predatory
old people not supposed to [ __ ] yeah
there is too much i think one years
older is pushing it the only age gap i'm
going for is ashlynn and gabe i think
they're a match made in heaven
and that's not predatory at all i think
i think women should have all the power
is what it is like you want them to be
the older person um yes um i'm trying to
smash the patriarchy
and um
yeah that's all i had to say quinn um i
feel like every dude that's my age sucks
so bad hey quinn do you think that maybe
you were talking about energies and he
was like oh no this is a weird crystal
having [ __ ] and so he didn't or like
any other time i would probably own up
to that but
he like
yeah he's a yoga instructor is this
ashley's ex-boyfriend rick
no his name isn't rick
welcome to dating in austin it's worse
not worse what's his name i'm going to
say
you're gonna say his last name yeah well
like a crazy name that like only one
okay so one time i was at i did
no
that's plot twist no one time i did an
open mic after a date back home and it
was a mic that like i only went to
sometimes and i just shot on a date that
i had gone on this guy i hadn't didn't
even know i did comedy no affiliation
with comedy
he just happened to be at the bar
that that
mike was that
and i um it was the day before that we
had the date and i just made fun of him
the entire time because i went on about
like what a shitty date it was like how
annoying he was but i was like but he
was six five so of course he [ __ ] and
then he was there
how did you not see a 6'5 guy in the
audience
i don't know um so that was rough
his name was kyle was he hurt was he
hurt yeah i don't think he's even paying
attention but i saw him and i think it
was one of those where i was like
he like uh these are like dogs he
probably didn't even notice he's
probably too dumb he's probably like
drinking beer and stuff he's an
astrophysicist
what
yeah but wasn't all about this astro for
never mind there was a joke back
there
so ahead i'll get it next time
i say that far too often
so you're telling me an astrophysicist
doesn't know how to talk to women no he
knew how to talk to women he was just
like
was really weird
did he know how to talk to a woman or
was he six five
oh
you got it
are you sure that he was uh he wasn't
the guy that was talking about the stars
and the energies and all that no this is
a different guy also charles
wait i have a theory
maybe he was autistic and he was like
the good doctor yeah like reminding
those but it's like i keep finding the
ones that they just aren't good at
social cues and don't talk but it's just
like i just wanna really like trains and
me
well good to know you went on a date
with neil degrasse tyson
that sounds exactly like him
but i don't know but that was the last
day that was friday
friday with the energy man energy he's
actually here in the room right now
he's not so much [ __ ]
he's springer
we actually have in the green room right
now
your energy conjured his energy
his ex-wife also here like
did he talk about his ex-wife i think he
was married i made that up just now i'm
starting rumors this is good improv i
believe
yes and um
yeah curtis what's the last thing you
went on before your fiance
before i like was
dating
before before i was dating my fiance
yeah it's a long time ago i got to think
i have no clue to you that's how old are
you you're 29 yeah
so you've been with her 20s since you
were 26 25 yeah 26. so college
early 20s you were just celebrating
people like a girl at bar like i just i
just it wasn't significant enough to
remember from three years ago he's
saying this with that of his fiancee
watches oh yeah for sure
for sure
because because she i think knows who my
last date was
wasn't it so why no
you don't want to talk about it
she doesn't have to say the name of the
person she just went on a date with on
friday i can uh i can make it with her i
did say that wait awesome
yeah it was kyle kyle
i thought it'd be something different
like more syllables also i think your
fiance would appreciate that you're
talking [ __ ] and making fun of the girl
and you're not like being like raising
her up and being like she's yeah i wish
my ex would say would have done that we
went to uh a bar and she was really
boring and like we i definitely went
home with her but then i never talked to
her again because like talking to a
brick wall
damn
i have a yelp and that's like all my
reviews
this is horrible
were you per chance doing astrophysics
in massachusetts five years i say i
can't do math like three times i think
so astrophysicists probably know you're
like keeping count like you have autism
says that's like stars no no um i
you are five nine it's
it's about shooting planes off right
like an airplane like i didn't even
barely graduate high school so i'm the
wrong person
fun and hip would it be for me to throw
in that i broke off an engagement to
move to austin
you were engaged i was engaged wow
curtis it's not too late you can also
break it off where'd you were from
tennessee oh see i'm in chicago and it's
it's cooler than here no offense
you and adam are both from chicago oh
yeah i thought he was from florida
no that's just like
he does look like he's from florida yeah
he does
you chicago guy is just always smiling
so you're always in a good mood what's
that i'm a sales person that's horrible
or south dakota i could see you being
from i'm from missouri which is
like he looks like he'd get
like beaten up in chicago
let's play hockey you look like that's
all your friends tell you to turn on
your location before you walk around
chicago
you look like a date rapist
it's just something i came up with
it's a little thing i'm working on
curtis uh so you you what do you like to
do in chicago this walk around the loop
um
yeah that's all there is to do there's
nothing the inner loop the outer loop no
i i'm into music
no molly
nice how did you guys how do you know
her i know i know her when i found out
today her ex-boyfriend
he said you were boring but he still
went to bed yeah yeah yeah i mean it was
it was really good
no um
he is friends with my ex-boyfriend i
thought they were dating until today too
yeah yeah until i got here
like that's what i found out like hey
remember me the guy that's friends with
the guy you hate now
don't hate him
greatest but uh he we had never met
before he was just a friend of my ex and
he hit me up being like hey i'm in
austin i was like okay come hang out and
we just started talking and you i was
like oh yeah i'm not with him anymore
and he was like oh i was wondering why i
asked him about you and he didn't
respond
curtis just because you're in a
successful relationship just assume you
know doesn't mean you got to rub it in
everyone's face
uh quinn have you ever like uh had to
run in with your ex or like ran into
someone that you knew like i moved to
austin texas to get away from my exes
it's like a reverse george strait yeah
got no x's and taxes yet
you will oh i can't wait yeah yeah
i actually just ended things with a guy
today
congratulations he was he's in tennessee
give it up for a quinn feel this time
seth i really did it
seth why are you like riding on this
what's going on well i went all the way
to colorado to see him to like end
things with him and then i didn't but
denver beautiful this time of year
y'all are wondering but i did today
through check okay well i'm proud of you
long distance kind of sucks and
denver
is kind of like a weird libtard place
like i don't really care about it so i
don't predict who do you think what do
you think
my uh next boyfriend will look like i'd
like to hear
seth oh
he has a girlfriend
oh nice verdict you have a chance
i see like a unicorn connelius kink out
of nowhere so quinn you broke up with
this guy yesterday or today today and
you went on a date friday well
[Laughter]
i would say uh
he was
i was much more into him than he was
into me so that i was just like but he
didn't mind that so just like
uh i'm done like
yeah do you because you were doing it
anyway so then i like i started doing it
too okay it's an open relationship yeah
but it wasn't even like a relationship i
was like this is my boyfriend and he's
like this is quinn
you know what i mean well that's a power
move yeah yeah yeah
that's super baller yeah does that
happen to you a lot hans
where girls cheat on me
yes surprisingly a lot
it's just because he's like this is my
girlfriend and they're like this is once
yeah a lot of girls uh after i go on
dates with them they go up on comedy
shows and talk massive amounts of [ __ ]
that's how i got my big break
curtis uh anything you want to say to
any of your exes
i i've only dated one woman before i
just leave it at that i'm telling you
i'm going to tell you i'm just yeah you
really are from the midwest yeah jesus
welcome to austin texas we're bisexual
here and it's no big deal
[ __ ] [ __ ] in bathtub we should have
messed up we throw up in bathtubs
we [ __ ] won't get a [ __ ]
penis sweet queen i feel like the
plumpkin's a florida thing though the
what the blumkin is a florida thing no
i'm surely not probably invented in
florida
but uh it might have been in missouri
actually now that i think about it's
just patented there
yeah yeah yeah it's just gotten really
popular in florida it's perfected in
florida it's like in all the halfway
homes halfway house in florida it's just
like golovkin because it's like a
horrible thing
you could never
you could never imagine was this in a
hotel or was it in a halfway house be
honest with us um
they call it a hotel
that was very classist of you to ask
yeah yeah yeah she brought up the
halfway house i didn't even bring it up
well
i can make a halfway house a halfway
home and
i christened it
with a blumkin
congratulations
congratulations he's getting married
give it up for curtis thank you for
going on a date with quinn quinn do you
want to go on one more date
me yeah sure
quinn's gonna go on a date with ridge
hershberger
did you sign up
oh
you did it yes
give it up for ridge the farmer
hershberger go on a date with wind
what's up
not much
gas prices am i right oh yeah tell me
about it so you like biden
uh
wow
do i look like a [ __ ] though
i do
hmm i don't think this is gonna work out
your first like collection on dating
apps is like so joe biden yeah do you
think he's a zombie or not
a zombie yeah like he could be an
external walking dude he's just i think
he's old as [ __ ]
anyways um
tell me something interesting about
yourself
um
there's like nothing i'm like so boring
like that's pretty much like all of my
reviews
boring is interesting
oh my gosh tell me something interesting
about you i'll play off that
i dated my cousin i believe that
guns in my head
pick out one classroom that's dated his
cousin i'm pointing to you in a room
full of 100 people uh
and quinn
wow
rich
you uh really don't want to get laid huh
i don't know
before well you got to talk to people
before you [ __ ] them here in austin well
wait ridge were your uh parents cousins
too
no
no they were siblings
but there is there's a lot of incest
in my area grief
he's amish almost country pennsylvania
yeah
yeah he's got a pool
yes we do hershberger memorial poll
what you didn't start with that i'm not
like uh i'm not like a hundred percent
my uncle he's amish
he's mixed realized
i'm like
i thought amish people and mormons were
the same until like two years ago
[Music]
like no you're talking about that they
show off my light switches
what are those
quinn have you ever dated like a redneck
yeah i'm from the east tennessee oh [ __ ]
yeah damn
what kind of rednecks do they have in
tennessee like like bootleggers
yeah we're all still moonshiners it's
1913.
are you all volunteers you guys
you know
construct dams and [ __ ]
tennessee valley authority all right
it's my credit union
actually um i dated like uh
rednecks that like i dated one redneck
guy
and he was like a he was a farmer
um well i really wanted to see a baby
cow and he wouldn't let me
that's the end of that story
like 250
jesus christ
[ __ ] everything
how are she supposed to get him pregnant
you want to see a hot this
cow
it's artificial insemination that's how
he keeps the beef so tender
[Laughter]
rich
what
um
no we have like a we have like a calf
born like every day this past weekend we
had like 12 so like if you ever want to
see a baby cathy it's really cool
it sucks when they're dead
it's crazy that ridge is over breeding
and i'm overeating
and that's what's happening on stage
right now
richard's been looking at your tits this
whole time
he wants to milk you
oh i was like
away and stared at a wall so quick that
no i haven't
i've been looking at it once i've been
looking at this wall
so many times crazy oh my god
high producer right here yeah
uh-huh
oh my god you like that
i'm nervous
have you ever farm life beyond what have
you [ __ ] farmland be honest what do
you mean [ __ ] farm life yeah livestock
oh
i don't know i have bread
i don't know it's kind of i mean when
you read a cow you put your arm in its
vagina that's kind of i mean it's like
foreplay i guess
i've got my tinder bio
no i haven't i thought the second
amendment was the right to bear arms not
the right to cow arms
kill tony regular
you just went for it too you was trying
to be bad so what do you do you put your
arm in and then you drop the sperm in
and then you loud or do you do
pumps
well you you put your you put your hand
in some lube first and then you stick
your arm in its [ __ ]
and then it's the sexiest thing you said
on that
the loop
wait really [ __ ] quick uh you do like
the tick tock dance like where you're
like firstly
you just line up the cows
i should just get those tick tockers to
come and breed could be tick-tock famous
if you took my advice i think
i i i do i do have a lot of followers on
tick tock
i uh literally just went like this like
i saw i saw yeah yeah
i uh
i squirt milk straight into my mouth
yeah um back to breeding cows
oh i just keep looking
so what's in your arm what's in your
hand
oh so in your hand you just have a you
have a sleeve on that goes like up to
your shoulder well not me but yeah you
do
i want to feel it don't you want to
bring a cow that would be a great video
yeah i would love to [ __ ] your cows
so
so where is when does the semen come in
i mean that is it and then you put a
it's like a it's like a straw
that's about three feet long
and then there's a metal rod sell them
yeah they're they're like uh yeah just
one tractor supply yeah yeah that's for
the turtle metal straw oh yeah
yeah
it's like it's like a ridge to suck out
all the semen which no one's ready
instead of putting in this even i just
go
i love these
no no no
um farm humor
that's probably like the second worst
farming date i've ever been on
fantasy baby wait i might not serve her
date so
i still have no idea how to [ __ ] a cow
yeah uh let's let's finish [ __ ] the
cast so then you put the rod in there
and you
no we don't we're not [ __ ] why did
you put your arm in there to begin just
stick the rod in right away well you
have to guide it through the cervix and
through the into the right horn it's
crazy that you probably know the inside
of a cow cervix more than a woman
that's crazy
he's like have you met my sister
he's getting utterly pissed off by it
she's so funny
yeah so then and then you just like
squirt it in there and you want to do it
slow cause i don't know why amen yeah
you want you want to light some candles
and do it slow but like when you're
reaching the [ __ ] you gotta you gotta
you hold the cervix through the [ __ ]
i don't know how it works but you reach
in there everything just feels like [ __ ]
okay
i think you uh went down a wrong turn
somewhere you went into the [ __ ] hole oh
the best date i've ever been on i uh
i invited this girl over to see a baby
cowboy born because it's real special
whenever like you see a life no it's
zach claibo
who's that um
he said his full name
so this calf was being born and i
like when they're born you gotta reach
in to make sure everything's
straightened up you're like the vet
and uh i was doing that she was watching
and she said let me try that and i said
no way
that's awesome
it was so hot that's what is a good day
i don't know
i regret it
like my boyfriend was 15 gives a [ __ ]
about what i'm doing right now what i'm
looking for in a date is the willingness
to [ __ ] a cow
i still dream about it
oh my god
what an interesting scenario we're in
quinn uh i mean uh ridge uh have you
ever dated a liberal before
and where is she now uh porous somewhere
she was uh she was like yeah yeah it
lasted for like two weeks i was like if
we i don't know she was like like a cat
lady she like had a whole bunch of cats
yeah she's a liberal man
and i was like i didn't i never asked
her her political affiliation
but i'm pretty sure she was and i was
like this isn't going to work out in the
long run you check democrat on your
voter registration they should give you
a cat
like and i hate cats so oh my god i love
cats i just can't eat a whole one by
myself am i right
you have to ask ons here to help you
like
got the asian jokes from the uh trump
supporter i'm i'm the china virus
china
what do you think about the
trade war
no trade war yeah it's great us farmers
are making so much money everybody
food's going skyrocketing yeah it's good
that we're starving but at least you're
making money
ask you a question but i think i'd
already know the answer
but like so you say you meet the love of
your life all right
she switches like bodies with your mom
like freaks friday
the only way to reverse it is you have
to [ __ ] one of their physical bodies
which one are you choosing wait the mom
or who your mom's body
you get either way i get to [ __ ] with
that mom
so if you're like girlfriend's
consciousness is in your mom's body and
vice versa but to reverse it you have to
[ __ ] one of them raw which one
this can this so could be a three-way
sentence
i don't i think uh the the i think i
understand your question
the i can say it's slower
if it would
yeah it's [ __ ] a bit fast
that was four syllables
yeah i only use one syllable words
uh my the mom's conscious in the in the
girlfriend's body you want your mom to
remember you [ __ ] her
i mean
i looked up it already does
why do you think i'm so good at it
one person's dying
[ __ ] your mom too yeah i mean to being
inside of cows
your ugly ass girlfriend
what would you do if it was your dad
did you answer the question because you
want your mom to remember mom's mom oh
because it's not i mean it wouldn't be
really her then it's her body yeah your
mom would understand your mom would
remember if you [ __ ] your mom's body
only your girlfriend remember like i
don't think you can catch
diseases from that if like we've had
kids
you know girls i don't get diseases from
either of them
oh yeah i hate to get an std from my mom
people people make fun of stds but at
least you're getting laid huh
he's like i'd [ __ ] my mind it's not
something you say so people thank you
rich what's that on your arm is that a
growth he like can't wait if he gets
like a like a zit on his lip he's like
it's herpes
thanks
i've never heard of arm herpes
i swear to god
herpes she goes to a different school
it's upstairs we're at a different
school different herd
but that's thank you for the show thank
you guys
for coming give it up for quinn and rich
thanks hans
follow ridge and ridge hershberger quinn
at sequiny c
molly vivint vivant at how did i get so
sexy
and uh thank you guys for coming out
every sunday at six
check out kelly's killer corn
kkc
yeah if you come to the front we'll
throw it in your mouth
there's an open mic yes
there is right
is
oh
um
you